Let me introduce you to a very interesting
effect known as the Doppler effect.
Which we can illustrate first of all,
becuase the engineers have recorded the sound
of a police car siren.
If we can have that?
[Siren sounds]
As it goes past you'll hear the drop in tone.
Well, we can simulate that by...
The police car is sending waves to us
and if I transmit waves, in imagination, along
this medium here.
We pretend that this is the air carrying the
sound waves to us.
One. Oh well that one...
I've got to do it in time with the metronome.
[Metronome ticks in the background]
Well, I think you've seen enough now to see
that,
the receiver hears exactly the same frequency
as I'm transmitting.
Now, if I'm moving away from him...
Sorry, I have to get that one on there like
that.
You'll see, he now has a lower frequency.
This corresponds to a change in the sound,
the sound is of a lower note.
But let me know, let me know do if I can,
go towards him, and you'll see the problem
rather increases for him.
If I increase my speed like that
you can have quite a job...
[Audience laughter]
Well, you see.
[Audience applause]
That is the doppler effect which enables us
to measure speeds.
And the beauty of it is that we measure speeds
at any distance
at optics we can't actually get to.
And it shows us that in our phrase, the universe
is expanding.